JONATHAN: Good
morning, and welcome
to Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce Ethan Zuckerman.
Ethan directs the Center
for Civic Media at MIT,
and he teaches at
MIT's Media Lab.
He's the co-founder of the
global blogging community
Global Voices, and he
works with social change
nonprofit organizations
around the world.
Much of his research centers
on quantitative analysis
of media, computational
techniques to determine who,
what, and where feature in
traditional and participatory
media.
He's here today to discuss
his book, "Rewire, Digital
Cosmopolitans in the
Age of Connection,"
now in paperback, which you've
never seen before today, so
small secondary thing, the
book which "Publisher's Weekly"
called "a fascinating and
powerful reflection on what
it means to be a citizen of
the world in the internet age."
Please join me in
welcoming Ethan Zuckerman.
[APPLAUSE]
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN: Thanks
so much, Jonathan.
And thanks, everyone,
for coming out.
I really appreciate it.
Obviously it's an arduous
trek from across the street
to be with you.
So as you guys know,
I'm sure, writing
is a bit of an isolated process.
And so you go into this
cave for 12 to 18 months,
and you shut everything
out of your head
when you try to
get the book out.
And then you put this
book out, and you
hope that the book
is still relevant.
You hope that the ideas
that you put forward still
help explain the world.
So I was really
gratified shortly
after the book came out to get
a story that sort of summed
up for me the core point
that I was trying to make.
And as it happens,
it's a Google story.
So I didn't make this up
especially for you guys.
This is the story
that I've been trying
to tell people to get a
sense for the phenomenon
that I'm talking about.
But it centers on
this guy Hugo Barra,
who's quite senior at Google,
working on the Nexus product,
very much the person who would
stand up and show everyone
where this remarkable
phone was going.
And you guys may remember
about 18 months ago
he announced that he was
going to leave Google.
And specifically he was
leaving Google for Xiaomi.
And Xiaomi was a company
that at that point
most Americans, including a lot
of Americans in the tech press,
knew very, very little about.
And so there was something
of a buzz in the tech press
around the idea
that someone would
leave this incredibly
prestigious job at Google
and go work for a Chinese
mobile phone manufacturer.
And so the tech press did
what they're so good at doing.
They actually dug deep down.
They found the story
behind the story.
And they started publishing
stories explaining
that what had
actually happened was
that Hugo Barra had
found himself involved
in a complicated love
triangle with Sergey Brin.
And of course, if you had
been dating a Googler,
and that Googler ended
up dating Sergey Brin,
there was only one logical
thing you could do.
You had to leave the United
States and go to a place
where Google's drones
couldn't reach.
And you were suddenly
outside of the orbit
of where Google
had any influence.
And this was obviously
the only thing
that could explain Barra
would give up a dream job
and find himself going to work
for a Chinese mobile phone
manufacturer.
And this got reported with a
fair amount of seriousness.
You can look this up and you can
find the stories of this triad.
And so Barra took to the
stage at LeWeb last winter,
and he said, guys, you
really just don't get this.
If you want to be working on
tech right now, particularly
if you want to be
working on mobile tech,
it's an amazing
time to be in China.
And it's not just
an amazing time
to be in China
because you're looking
at 500 million people
on the internet,
you're looking at this
massive emergent middle class.
It's not just a great
time to be there
because Xiaomi is actually
a pretty interesting company
and doing innovative things on
top of the Android operating
system and building
really beautiful phones
and running them in small runs
on a unique business model.
It's an interesting
time to be in China
because the Chinese
internet does not
look a whole lot
like the US internet.
And in fact, a lot
of the tools that
have become dominant
in the Chinese internet
actually don't have
very neat US parallels.
We talk often about Weibo
as being sort of Twitter
on steroids.
It's actually significantly more
interesting in political terms.
It's really become sort of the
space for public discourse.
WeChat with the circles model
has done something that even
Google has actually had trouble
getting across with Plus,
but a really different
model for communication
within small groups
that's worked very well.
Alipay has brought digital cash
into ordinary, everyday use
in a way that, again,
isn't all that common
at this point in
the US or in Europe.
As much as we may be impressed
by what our friends over Amazon
are doing as far
as delivery, JD.com
putting things on people's desks
within four hours of ordering
is really an order of
magnitude beyond this.
And so I don't
expect these stories
to be particularly surprising
in a room like this.
But generally what I'm going
out and talking about what's
going on on the
Chinese internet,
I get a whole lot of
bafflement, because there's
this sense in which we
expect the Chinese internet
to be boring and stultified and
censored and non-generative.
And in fact, in
many ways it's one
of the most interesting spaces
that's going on right now.
And so I'm not actually here to
talk about the Chinese internet
and why we should take the
Chinese internet seriously,
although it's a fun topic
and an interesting one.
What I really want to talk
about is this broader notion
that I've been wrestling
with in this book, which
is this possibility that atoms
may, under circumstances, be
more mobile than bits.
We're actually remarkably
connected to China
in terms of getting stuff
in and out of China.
We've all gotten our
heads used to the idea
that we are engaged
in supply chains that
are deeply global in form.
And you start
thinking about what's
involved with building the
laptop that I'm presenting
from, and you're involving
50 or 60 countries.
You've got container ships
moving between all of them.
And this sort of miracle of
a designed-in-California,
made-in-China,
delivered-directly-to-me
product gives you a sense of
just how connected these sort
of networks have been.
What's interesting
is that I'm making
the argument in this book
that the digital networks that
tie us together don't
actually work as effectively.
And the way to get
this is you can't
think about these networks
in terms of potential.
You have to think about
them in terms of flow.
You can't just
think about the idea
that in theory we're
capable of getting
all sorts of
information out of China
or all sorts of information
out of Sub-Saharan Africa.
What I'm really asking is, where
does that information flow?
It's really hard to map flow.
We get it a little
bit when we look
at a map like a
visualization of traffic.
And we look at the
city of Cambridge,
but we also look at
where you want to drive
and where you don't want
to drive at that point.
This is a map of air
routes that actually
does a nice job of flow.
You get out of it is a
sense that you can probably
get to any point in the world.
But if you start looking for
where it's particularly thick,
where it's
particularly connected,
you start getting
very good indicators
of where people
actually go in practice.
But even a map like
this tends to disguise
a little bit what's going on.
What actually happens when
you look at air traffic
is that about 90%
of it is domestic.
It's actually almost
a rounding error,
the international traffic.
We think about it when we start
thinking about how we interact
with people from
other countries.
We think about it when we think
about how disease spreads.
about just-in-time delivery.
But in fact, the vast majority
of this ends up being domestic.
And what I'm finding is
that the same thing ends up
happening when we start dealing
with flows of information.
By the way, I have to think that
this is one of the great intern
projects of all time, right?
This guy Paul Butler
goes over to Facebook,
says I'd like to map
Facebook, gets enough data
that he's able to do
this visualization.
You can find Zuckerberg
pointing to this map
every single time he talks about
Facebook's global ambitions.
So just in terms of
like constructing
a map as rhetorical
document, I have
to think that this is
sort of a fun thing.
But what this map very
clearly wants to tell
you is that Facebook is this
incredibly global network.
What it actually doesn't do a
very good job of telling you
is how much of that
traffic on that network
is people who are
literally in the same town,
in the same city,
in the same country.
We've got this illusion, this
vision of the cosmopolitan
by looking at a network that
theoretically connects us all.
But when we start
asking this question--
where are we actually
getting our information?--
what are we actually paying
attention to?-- are we hearing
the story about Xiaomi?-- are
we hearing about Ebola before it
becomes a crisis?--
in many cases,
we're actually dealing with a
remarkably disconnected world.
And for me, what I
study much of the time
is what we pay attention
to in news media.
And so this is a tool.
This is actually
publicly available
if you want to play
around with it.
We are scraping 50,000
media sources in the US
and then doing
visualizations day
to day based on our own
geocoding coming out of it just
to get a sense of what
we're paying attention to
and the incredible imbalance
between domestic news
and international news.
In some senses it makes sense.
Everybody pays more
attention to what's
going on domestically than
they do internationally.
But the extent to
which, at a moment where
it's almost possible to get
information from anywhere,
we have a tendency
to be overwhelmed
by domestic information, is to
me sort of a surprising one.
But I want to talk about
why I'm interested in this.
And for me, it has a lot
to do with my own history.
I got involved with building
internet-based businesses
in 1994.
I was the founding CTO for
a company called Tripod.com,
which did homepage hosting.
It get swallowed by Lycos.
like: Lycos got sold off into
a million different parts.
But a lot of the
things that people
working on user-generated
content businesses
are dealing with now we were
dealing with in the late 1990s.
I came out of that
and said, well,
this is really interesting.
We built a really
big company that
was the eighth largest site
on the web for a little while.
We built it in a
town of 8,000 people
in northwestern Massachusetts.
I wonder if we could
do it in West Africa.
Because of course that's
a logical next step.
It's western Mass, West Africa.
So I started a group that
invited technology volunteers
to come over for three
to six months at a time
and work in start-up
businesses in West Africa
and try to do tech transfer
and help businesses get off
the ground.
And believe it or not,
this is in 1999 one
of the hottest businesses
on the continent.
This is Joy Online,
which has turned
into Ghana's main
international portal.
If you're a Ghanaian living
anywhere else in the world,
this is your source of news
and commerce and revenue.
This is your connection
to the rest of the world.
And so I was hanging
out in Accra, Ghana
with these businesses and
seeing amazing things,
people building really
fascinating businesses,
high levels of technical
sophistication,
wondering why the world
hadn't figured out
that Ghana was going to
be a great destination
for outsourcing.
And then something really
interesting happened.
Ghana had an election, a
really good election in 2000,
elected this guy John Kufuor.
And Kufuor was an
interesting guy.
He came from the opposition
party, the party that
had been in power for
more than 20 years,
gave up power voluntarily.
This guy got elected in an
election that was universally
seen as free and fair.
And as you can tell, it
dominated all the news
in the newspapers.
So we, just to
remind you in 2000,
were having a bit of an iffy
election here, Bush v. Gore,
didn't go actually
all that smoothly.
It was actually
going so badly here
that Ghana offered election
observers to come down
to Florida to try to help
them run this election.
And unfortunately, this
incredibly good news story
out of Africa ended
up getting something
like 200 words in
the "New York Times."
And I was looking at this
and essentially saying,
there is no way that I
can do what I'm doing.
There's no way that
I can figure out
how to get American
companies to take Sub-Saharan
Africa seriously
unless we start looking
at this question of what
we pay attention to.
And so I started
a scholarly career
looking at this question
of, how do we pay attention
to the rest of the world?
And what's been really
weird about this
is there's a huge shrinkage
in international attention.
If you looked at international
newscasting in the 1970s,
at least one out
of three stories
was an international story.
Now, there's some
reasons for this, right?
This is the height of the
Vietnam War, a lot of this
is America's
involvement in Vietnam.
But there was a lot more
international attention
at that particular
moment in time.
And this erosion in
broadcast coverage
is due to a lot of
different things.
It's due to cost.
It's a lot cheaper to
cover domestic events.
To a funny extent,
politicians sort
of cover themselves,
as do celebrities,
whereas wars actually require
you get out on the ground.
This has happened not
just in broadcast.
We've replicated this finding in
print in the UK and in the US.
We've seen a 45% decrease in
coverage of international news
stories between the
1970s to the last decade.
And when you think
about it, this
goes completely
counter to what we
would expect from
the technology.
We would expect that in
the 1960s and 1970s when
it was incredibly challenging
to go and get these stories--
you had to go to
Vietnam, shoot on film,
put the film in a canister,
ship it across an ocean,
develop it, and then put it up
for broadcast-- that we would
have a lot more information
coming out at a moment
where you can put a crew on the
ground with a satellite phone,
with a camera, get footage
from Haiti within 12
hours of disaster happening.
But most the time, that
isn't actually what happens.
And one of the big reasons
why it doesn't happen
is that we have a surprisingly
light appetite for news.
This is work that I did just
scraping off of Ad Planner,
back when you guys left it
open and I could scrape it,
just trying to get
a sense for what
was the appetite for domestic
versus international news
in the largest internet
markets, so just looking
at how much attention was
paid to various different news
sites.
Turns out that
the US is actually
quite cosmopolitan in
our news attitudes.
We pay a lot of
attention to the BBC.
We have a very large Indian
expatriate population
that religiously reads
"Times of India."
But even with that
much internationalism,
we're at roughly 94%
domestic sources.
So consider "The Guardian,"
consider the BBC,
consider all of that.
We have a strong preference
for the domestic.
It's much, much stronger in
most other nations, this sort
of promise that we could
look at the internet,
and I could read the
"Times of India,"
I could read various different
Australian or Chinese papers
depending on my language skills.
Most of the time
this is not where
we end up spending
our attention.
So we end up actually very
dependent on the coverage that
comes out of mainstream media.
And that coverage
has had biases that
have stuck with us for
a very, very long time.
I've been mapping the "New York
Times" for about 10 years now.
I actually have to mark
my maps very carefully,
because I can never
tell by looking at them,
because the pattern
doesn't really change.
We're almost always
under-covering
Sub-Saharan Africa.
We're very rarely
covering Central Asia.
We tend to have a very,
very strong interest
in North America,
Western Europe,
and increasingly
in India and China.
But of course, now we're
in a digital age, right?
So we've got
infinite shelf space.
We're not constrained
by what comes out
on the paper "New York Times."
Now you start seeing something
like the Huffington Post trying
very, very hard to
internationalize.
And what you'll see
looking between the two
is you actually end up
with a much paler map.
You end up with significantly
less international exposure
as you start moving from
the Times into HuffPo.
You actually have a much
stronger concentration
of stories coming out
of the United States,
stories coming out of Europe.
And so this is
why, in many cases,
people sort of look and
say, well, wait a second.
OK, so we still
have strong biases
within existing
mainstream media.
As we're moving
into digital media,
we're ending up with possibly an
even more Ameri-centric media.
What about this graph?
Aren't we going to get
interesting international news
through our friends?
As social kicks
in, aren't we going
to find out about
really important stories
because our friends in other
countries know about them?
So I had the great
good fortune to get
to interrogate this
data a little bit
with a guy named Johann Ugander,
who wrote this very, very
helpful paper on the anatomy
of the Facebook social graph.
And what this paper
suggests is actually
a pretty surprising to
folks like me who study
international contact.
It's suggested that 15% of
the relationships on Facebook
cross international boundaries.
And I found myself looking at
this and going, that's amazing.
That's so much
higher than we would
get in any other
sort of statistic.
And so we hammered
at it a little bit.
And as we hammered at it,
we discovered, first of all,
that a lot of this
was coding error.
It's actually closer to 10%
that was actually international.
And that 10% international
is actually highly clustered.
To the extent that Scandinavians
hang out with other people,
they hang out with
other Scandinavians.
To the extent that
people in South America
hang out with other
people online,
it's other people
in South America.
And that's more or less
what this graph shows us.
But what we found that was
most remarkable in this
is that the average
person has more like 2%
to 3% international ties
rather than 10% to 12%
international ties.
And the reason for this is
if you are a Norwegian living
and working in
the United States,
you show up as having 80%
or 90% international ties
within this data set, because
you're using something
like Facebook to stay in
touch with everyone at home.
So you may be what we refer
to as a bridge figure.
You may be someone who is able
to bring interesting stories
from Norway and bring
it into a US audience
if that US audience is capable
of paying attention to it.
But you are a very, very small
subset of the population.
And the rest of
that population is
dealing with a social network
delivering them stories
and delivering them
information that's
really governed by the
phenomenon of homophily.
So homophily was a
word that I didn't
know before I sat down to
start writing this book.
When I found myself
dealing with it,
it unlocked a whole trove of
sociological literature for me.
Turns out that homophily,
which is basically
the tendency of birds of a
feather to flock together,
is probably the best
documented finding
in contemporary sociology.
People are incredibly
good at self-selecting
into comfortable tribes
of one fashion or another.
We see evidence that in
neighborhoods, people
will move in next to
people of the same race,
next to people of similar
socioeconomic status.
You see the same thing when
you walk into a cafeteria
and people don't know
each other very well.
They tend to cluster by visible
characteristics like race.
But if you actually
interview, you'll
find out that their
unconsciously very
good at clustering
themselves by religion,
by socioeconomic status.
One of my favorite
papers in this space
looks at students walking
into a computer lab
and finds that
students end up sitting
next to people who have
similar facial features.
If you wear glasses,
you're likely to sit
down next to someone
who has glasses.
If you have long
hair, you sit down
next to someone
who has long hair.
And when you interview
people after the fact
to try to explain this, they
say, they looked friendly.
We're really good at
trying to find our tribe.
And what's
interesting about this
is that this tendency to
find our tribe, I think,
is playing out online as well.
When we're dealing
with curated media,
like the "New York Times," we
pay more attention to our tribe
than to the other tribes.
We pay more attention to
North America and to Europe
than we do to anywhere else.
And in some ways,
the further we get
in terms of cultural
distance, when
we're talking about something
like Sub-Saharan Africa,
you're going to get less
and less information.
As we move into an era of
choice, where I, as the user,
say, this is what I
want to know about,
when I search for something,
when I customize my news,
anything within that
paradigm basically
now depends on my ability to
be conscious of my own choices.
And unconsciously, I'm
likely to pay more attention
to people who are like me.
And so when I think about,
give me what's important,
give me what I need to
know about in the world,
I am likely to have a somewhat
biased approach to it based
on my own natural tendencies
to pay attention to my tribe.
And now as we start moving
into an era of social media,
it's interesting
that this is going
to play itself out even further.
Because most of us have pretty
homophilous social networks.
We have a strong
bias towards people
who have the same ideology,
who have the same religion, who
have the same basic background.
And if you think about the fact
that a network like Facebook
starts by literally trying to
recreate your high school class
and put you back into
your town of origin
and connect you with
all those people,
you have a very, very
strong homophilous bias
to what sort of information
comes in through there.
Now the argument that
I'm making, by the way,
is actually pretty different
from Eli Parser's argument
in "The Filter
Bubble." he's saying
it's all about the algorithms.
They're lying to you.
They're just trying to
give you what you want.
I'm actually saying the problem
is much worse than that.
The simple problem
is, because we
have this very strong natural
tendency to pay attention
to those who have a
lot in common with us,
even a completely unbiased, a
completely un-logarithmically
controlled network, would
still fall into something
of this homophily trap
that I'm talking about.
So why should we
care about this?
I think the big
reason for me to care
about this is that the really
big, really interesting
problems probably don't
get solved locally.
It's very hard to
find someone who
believes that addressing
climate change in a serious way
is going to be something
that the US does by itself.
There may be
technological innovation.
There may be major
breakthroughs.
But at the end of the
day, this challenge
of trying to figure out how
China, how India, how Myanmar,
how Nigeria industrialize
without having the same carbon
footprint that we have is an
enormous international problem
that's actually going to
require us to have conversations
with the emerging middle
class in those countries
and try to figure out how to
both meet their aspirations
and also try to
minimize the impact.
But I think in some
ways, we actually
have gotten a much
better example just
in trying to figure
out what's happened
with Ebola over the
last couple of months.
If you spend as much time
reading about West Africa
as I do-- and I do it, again,
because of my own homophilous
tendencies, right?
I hang out with a
lot West Africans.
I read West African news.
We knew that this outbreak was
something particularly scary
and particularly
serious in mid-March.
But what's interesting
about it is
that there was almost
no attention to it.
This is part of the
same suite of tools
that I was showing before.
This is the media
cloud set of tools.
And what I'm looking at here is
the 25 largest-audience US News
sources.
And what I'm looking at here is
a search for Ebola and Guinea,
which is that orange line there.
And you'll see that back
in March, back in April,
we were talking a little
bit about Ebola in Guinea.
We have almost nothing
until the crisis really
starts getting out
of control in Guinea.
People are really,
really worried
that large chunks of the country
are going to get knocked out.
And we're talking
about this in July.
Now, the blue line,
by contrast, shows you
how we normally pay
attention to this.
That's the search string
"Ebola and Texas."
So as soon as this
hits national borders,
as soon as this hits
people like us, people
that we pay attention to,
people that we care about,
we have this massive
surge in attention.
The thing is, it's too late.
This is now actually a
very serious epidemic.
It's going to affect tens
of thousands of people.
It's possible that
West Africa is
going to end up being a
reservoir for this disease
for some significant
time to come.
We could have had a
great deal of impact
on this had we jumped
into it very early on.
But it's incredibly
hard for epidemics
to get onto the news agenda.
They're not like earthquakes,
where happens one day,
it's an act of God, and everyone
sort of rallies together,
and let's go save Haiti.
It's the kind of thing
that you actually
have to pay attention
to day after day
and get a sense of
how serious it is.
And there's a great
story on "Planet Money"
about why it has proved almost
impossible to raise money
to fight the Ebola epidemic.
And instead, what
we have are people
and in essentially saying,
let's just shut our doors.
I think Ebola is actually a
lovely example of why this just
doesn't make any sense.
We know that people are going
to keep going back and forth.
We know that people who are
caring for their families
in West Africa are going to
find ways to cross borders.
They're going to end up
doing it perhaps by lying.
And if they lie about
where they've been,
we're not going to
be able to monitor.
We're not going to be able
to take people's temperatures
twice a day for 21 days.
We're also going
to lose the ability
to send the medical
personnel who
want to go over and
actually help with this
and be able to go
back and forth.
This is one of these
situations where this tenancy
to say, we should just
withdraw from the world,
when you start playing
it through, really
doesn't make a
whole lot of sense.
This is a situation that
in a connected world
we all end up having
some responsibility for.
But I think the reason
to care about this stuff
isn't purely negative.
And where I end
up in the book is
talking about
affirmative reasons
why you might want
to be paying more
attention to the
rest of the world.
And a lot of this
leans on this guy
Ron Burt at
University of Chicago.
And Ron left U Chicago
to go work for Raytheon
and to pretty much conduct
just one of the greatest
social science
experiments of all time.
He got himself hired as a senior
vice president at Raytheon
just as Raytheon was trying to
integrate five new companies
that they'd found the money
to pay for after inventing
the Patriot missile.
And so you've got a
giant defense contractor
trying to figure out its
own internal structure,
how does it work
and how do ideas
spread within the company.
So he takes one department.
He takes Internal Purchasing.
And he interviews everybody
in the entire company,
more than 1,000
people, and says,
write down your best idea.
How would you make
Raytheon better?
People write them up.
He anonymizes them.
He puts them in front
of senior management.
Senior management ranks
all of these ideas,
identifies the people
within the organization
who have the best ideas.
And he tries to figure out
what this might correlate to.
You would hope that this would
correlate to your highest
ranking people, your
most experienced people.
The answer is no, actually--
fairly loose correlation
between whether you've been
with Raytheon for a while,
whether you're in a senior
management position,
whether you have a
good idea or not.
It correlates incredibly
closely to the sociogram
of the organization.
If you are a bridge
between structural holes,
if you are someone who travels
between different offices,
if you are the person
in the Hong Kong office
who is in touch every day
with the Honolulu office,
if you are someone who has
moved throughout the company
and so you have ties in a
lot of different offices,
you are at, as Bert puts
it, an alarmingly high risk
of having good ideas.
He's able to look at
this whole organization
and essentially say, we
think the best ideas,
as judged by management, are
coming from the people who
have the access to the most
diverse ways of looking
at a problem.
And he ends up
coming out of this
with a really
interesting theory.
He says, creativity is an
import-export business,
that we think about
genius in terms
of being Picasso and being able
to see the world in an entirely
different way.
But what genius is
most of the time
is taking something
that's incredibly
ordinary in another
setting and putting it
into a totally
different setting.
And as it turns out, I'm not
just randomly juxtaposing
Picasso and a mask from Benin.
Picasso started collecting
West African artwork shortly
before he invented cubism.
And if you think about
Cubism, what it largely is,
is about taking these
sort of geometric shapes
that come out of
African mask-making
and bring it into
high art painting.
Burt suggests that one of
our ways to try to be Picasso
is to try to figure out how
to diversify those information
networks.
How do we amplify our
cognitive diversity?
How do we make sure
that we are interacting
with enough different people
who see a problem in enough
different ways that we're
able to actually approach it
from multiple
different approaches?
So I've been working
on this question,
this question of, how would
we build an internet that's
good for looking at the entire
world, for the last 10 years
or so.
And I'm really bad at it.
And one of the
reasons why it's fun
to come to a place like
this is because the things
that I've done so far
have been so remarkably,
dramatically unsuccessful.
This is the dramatically
unsuccessful project
I've been working
on for 10 years.
This is a community
called Global Voices.
It's about 1,200 volunteers
in about 130 countries.
They put out a daily
newsletter of what's
going on in social media
all over the world.
And so if people
right now in Djibouti
are talking about whether the
overthrow of the government
in Burkina Faso provides
a model for Djiboutians
to rise up against their
government, we've got it.
And that happens to be the
lead story this morning.
If people are talking
about pop music in Ukraine,
and that was a lead
story the other day,
that's what we've got out there.
And our whole idea behind this
was we'd go after the supply.
We would basically
say, we know that we've
shrunk how much
time we're spending
on television or in the
newspaper international news.
Let's go after the digital.
We will look for people who
are great bridge figure.
These are people who are
within these countries
but also speak English.
They can help you figure out
what's actually going on,
what might you want
to pay attention to.
And while I think the model
is really good, what we never
thought about was demand.
And we've never managed to get
this product more than about
a million people a month.
There's about a million
people who are actually
quite passionate about it.
They spend a lot of time on it.
They're really excited about it.
But most people
either don't agree
or haven't gotten
the message that you
would want to think about how
you get more diversity of what
you're paying attention to.
And so I've started working on
a very different paradigm, which
is the Fitbit paradigm.
So I would like to be a smaller,
less substantial person.
For a very, very
long time I have
been wearing this
thing in my pocket,
and it helps me
figure out whether I
want to change my
behavior on any given day,
get a little bit
more walking in.
And what I'm finding is that
I now want a Fitbit for media.
I want to find some
way to let people
see what they're
paying attention to
and what they're not
paying attention to.
And that's what underlies
most of this research
around the media cloud products,
is trying to figure out,
could we make it
possible for you
to monitor what you're likely to
be knowledgeable about and not
knowledgeable about
based on the media
that you end up consuming?
And my students have
started picking this up
in really interesting ways.
One of my doctoral
students, Nathan Matias,
makes me show this
slide using my own data,
because it's a really nice
way to put me on the spot.
He's written very, very
good open source tools
called Open Gender Tracker
that make educated guesses
at the gender of someone
that you're reading.
And looking at who
I follow on Twitter,
I follow a lot more
men than women.
And this turned out to be the
case for almost everybody who
has ended up using this.
I've actually found many of the
women in my professional circle
will check two accounts.
They'll have a
professional account,
where they're following
twice as many men as women.
They'll have a personal account,
which is much closer to 50/50
or further along.
But the whole idea is when
you can make this visible,
you can start making
conscious choices on this.
I am a lot less likely to follow
some random dude on Twitter
than I am to follow an
interesting moment who
comes into my stream
because I have
to show this slide every
time I talk about this,
and I'm embarrassed by it
every single time I do it.
I have another
student who's been
doing wonderful work
trying to figure out
whether we can use the web and
some element of self-monitoring
to try to bring some serendipity
into what you encounter online.
And so she's built a tool that
looks at what news you read,
figures out what parts of the
world you're reading about,
and then when you open a new
browser tab simply sends you
to a different city,
gives you the city map,
gives you reading
suggestions, tries to push you
in a direction of reading
about something unfamiliar.
What I'm feeling really
good about in this
is that I'm not
alone on this one.
Of the things that's
been very interesting is
to see Sir Tim Berners-Lee,
25 years into the web,
standing up and saying, I'm not
sure we got the web we want.
I'm not sure that the web that
we got, in Sir Tim's case,
is a global enough, is open
enough, is free enough.
And he's now trying
to get people together
to look at this question-- do
we have to be stuck with the web
that we have?
And I think this mission, this
vision of essentially saying,
we could fix what
we have, we could
make something very different--
if you share my sentiment
that it's important
to have a more
global view of the world coming
out of it, people in this room
are actually in a
remarkably good place
to think about how you would
actually go ahead and rewire
and try to think about how you
would put together a web that
was better at making us
globally knowledgeable and more
cosmopolitan.
So that's what I'm working on.
That's what I'm thinking
about in this book.
The book is now
out in paperback.
So if you had been
restricted by thinking about
whether my ideas were
interesting enough
to carry 1 and 1/2
pounds of them around,
it's now down to
about half a pound.
So if I've hit the
half-pound threshold,
you should definitely
go get a copy of it.
But I really appreciate
you listening.
I'm happy to take some
questions if anyone has any.
[APPLAUSE]
Please.
AUDIENCE: The first thing
is the guy at Raytheon
who found that the bridge people
are more creative-- has anyone
replicated that looking for
the direction of causality?
Because my suspicion is
that many of the people who
gravitate to those roles
have a certain kind
of way of thinking.
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN: Yup, yup.
AUDIENCE: And then
the other one is,
you seem to focus a lot
on geographic diversity.
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN:
Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
is that just a limit
you have because of how you
think about the problem?
And do you know
anyone else who's
thinking of it as non-geographic
in terms of diversity.
I mean, you did the
gender on Twitter.
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN:
Yeah, yeah. yeah.
Yeah.
No, thank you.
That's an awesome
pair of questions.
So the Rob Burt work has been
looked at very, very closely.
That's a paper with
like 5,000 cites to it.
What most people have
looked at is actually
Raytheon's total inability to
use the suggestions he made.
So essentially having
identified the smart people
in the company, why
has Raytheon continued
to be such a disaster?
I don't know
specifically of someone
who's verified your
hypotheses, but I
think it's really
nice, which is,
you may have certain people
gravitating to that place.
In the book, I use Burt to talk
about this idea of a bridge
figure.
And for me, a bridge
figure is someone
who's sort of straddling
two different worlds.
And it's not just that
you're bicultural.
There are a lot
of people who are
bicultural who choose
not to be a bridge.
They're not actually interested
in brokering between the two.
I think there probably
is a bridge personality.
I wouldn't be surprised
at all to find
that bridge personalities
gravitate there.
You're totally right on
the extent to which I'm
using geography as an
imperfect proxy for diversity.
And what I end up talking about
in the book is I go further
with it, is essentially saying,
what I'm really interested in
is cognitive diversity.
I'm really interested
in this question of,
do you look at the world
in a different way?
By spending a pretty substantial
chunk of my adult life in West
Africa, I can
definitely tell you
that the average
West African has
a really different and
sometimes more hopeful
set of cognitive tools to
take on different problems.
And it has to do with
an educational system.
And it has to do with the
society that you live in.
But there's no guarantee that
that geographic difference
is going to turn into
a cognitive difference.
You can imagine taking a
friend of mine out of a West
African primary
school, educating them
in the same schools that I've
been in, working the same jobs
that I do, we're going to
end up thinking a lot alike
in many ways.
There are definitely
people looking
at questions around
gender diversity,
around racial and
ethnic diversity.
Over in our lab, the student
of mine, Nathan Matias,
has been doing really
good, deep work
on gender diversity and
representation in media.
And there's actually a
very helpful community
around there trying to
get a sense for why is it
that it's only 16% of op
eds are written by women?
And is this a place where
you could sort of put a lever
and try to get not
only gender diversity
but cognitive diversity
in the process?
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have
a question about-- I
like your comments about
connectedness in the world,
right?
And to some degree,
I think you expressed
maybe some disappointment
about how even
the connections that
there are internationally,
that they are sort of obvious
to some degree, right?
Me as a German, I might be more
connected to other Germans,
so these connections are worth
less to some degree, right?
I wonder if we have enough
tools for these kind of things.
Like I mean, you mentioned like
the cafeteria model, right?
You go into a
cafeteria and you sit
next to people that are
similar to yourself, right?
And I think in social
networks, it always
tends to be that all the
new connection you make
are obvious given the kind
of things you do, right?
You travel to a
remote office and then
maybe you get connected to
people in that remote office,
right?
Do you know if
there's any good tools
to get randomly
connected, like sort
of like a sort of
virtual cocktail hours,
where you just socialize with
completely random people that
also are interested
in socializing
with other completely
random people?
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN: So there's
two approaches to this problem.
There are people who've
done pure randomness.
And pure randomness doesn't
work necessarily all that well.
To a certain
extent, Chatroulette
is pure randomness, right?
That was kind of the
theory behind it.
Let's just open a chat
window, someone else
arbitrarily in the room.
The emergence of
the social norms of,
and now let me show you my
genitals, was sort of emergent
on top of that platform.
But that may simply
be where you end up
when you're dealing with
sort of pure randomness
and pure anonymity.
And there are people
playing with it.
And then there are
services like StumbleUpon
that are sort of trying
almost pure random.
There's an app called
Random that works on this.
The ones that I'm actually
much more interested in
are trying to
engineer serendipity.
And they're looking
for a connection
where some aspect of it
is something in common,
and some aspect of it
is something unexpected.
So two really quick
models on this.
Like a lot of people, like a lot
of geeks my age, I miss Usenet.
And I miss sort of
the early '90s Usenet.
And what I specifically miss
about the early '90s Usenet
was that it was a
topic-organized internet.
So if I found
myself on rec.photo,
there was a good
chance that I was
going to run into someone from
Japan or someone from Finland,
but we were going to have
enough in common round emergent
digital photography that
we would have a reason
to have a conversation.
And then we might have more
of that geographic diversity,
maybe more of the gender
diversity, more of the income
diversity coming from
having that topic in common.
Where I'm now sort of
thinking about this
is I actually think
Twitter is potentially
a very interesting
tool for this.
Because the connection
is pretty lightweight.
You're sort of
sharing information.
And so part of what I'm trying
to do-- one of the things we're
playing around
with right now is,
can I try to figure out what
your community of interests
looks like on Twitter?
And can I find a community that
is related but sufficiently
different?
So if I'm a social media
guru or whatever the hell
that means in the US, can I
find that person in Nigeria?
And in having that
element of difference
as well as that
element of similarity,
can there be enough that
we're likely to have
that really
profitable connection,
but enough difference
that we're likely to have
something else of it?
It's a really hard problem.
And in doing sort of reading
recommendation around it,
which is what Catherine
D'Ignazio and I
spent a lot of time doing on
that Terra Incognita problem.
We actually figured out that
it's probably not as simple as
hi, have a chat.
It's probably more like, can
I give you enough information
that you would have something
to have a chat about?
And so the model
that I'm in some ways
really interested in is one
that started in Scandinavia,
is now sort of playing out
in public libraries, which
is the human library, which is
you identify a set of people
from very different
walks of life,
very different backgrounds.
You put them in the library,
and you offer someone
the opportunity to
go check out a person
and sort of have a conversation.
And whenever this has
been done at libraries,
it sort of sells out
almost immediately.
My wife and I were
sort of arguing over
who got to do it at Williams
College in Williamstown,
and we figured that random
professorial type was not
as appealing as rabbi,
which was her identity.
And so she signed up as
a rabbi and had like 9
of her 10 slots filled
almost immediately.
The one guy who was more
popular out in deep blue Western
Massachusetts was Gun Owner.
And everyone wanted to
go talk to this guy.
And I'm now actually taking
shooting lessons from the guy.
So there are really
interesting things
that sort of happen when
you set up structures
to allow people to meet.
But I agree with you.
I think in many
cases, it's something
where we would want
to do a lot more work.
Please.
AUDIENCE: This is sort
of a modeled question,
but I think-- well, my
viewpoint anyway-- we
have a bit of a problem with
this partisan echo chamber.
You can select news
sources that are never
going to deliver you information
that challenges your worldview.
But if I go look for
information sources
that are not from my
partisan perspective,
I wind up reading op
eds that sort of make
me want to throw a brick
through my computer screen.
And I don't know-- do you have
any thoughts on if there's
a way out of this trap of
you want information that
challenges you, but you don't
want information or opinion,
maybe, that is repugnant.
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN: I think
that's exactly right,
and by the way, not
a muddled question,
a nicely put question and right
at the heart of some really
interesting debates
going on in the space.
There's a huge
debate going on about
whether the internet is
separating us politically.
And I would say on one side,
probably the best articulated
is a guy named Cass
Sunstein, who has said,
I've done experiments
in deliberation.
You put people in the room
with like-minded people,
people get more extreme.
If I hang out with the far
left, I get further left.
You hang out with the far
right, you get further right.
Gentzkow and Shapiro, really
pair of economists at Chicago,
wrote a paper
essentially saying,
no, no, no, the
internet's actually
much better than the
rest of the media.
You're actually going to
get more diverse audiences.
It's a really
controversial paper.
I take it on at some
length in the book
and come to a different
conclusion than they come to.
But they're better
economists than I am,
so they may be right.
I may be wrong.
My take on this would
be the first instinct,
which is, OK, let
me turn on Fox News,
and I'm going to understand
what they're thinking about,
is probably wrong.
Because you're going to the
absolute opposite pole of where
you are.
And it's really hard
to look at this other
than, that's the enemy, I want
to figure out who they are,
and I want to undercut them.
I actually think
the thing to do is,
when you're sort of
orthogonal with someone,
to try to figure out how you
get the optimum sort of angle
of consonance, right?
So if I'm looking for a
conservative viewpoint
that I might want to
pay real attention to,
I'm not going to
look for someone
who's contemptuous of
science and someone who's
deeply religious and someone
who's from the American South.
What I might end
up looking for is
someone who is also from New
England, also in academia,
but happens to think really
different things than I do.
And when I'm able to
find those people,
I find myself much
more challenged.
And so that may only be a
15 degrees of difference
rather than 180
degrees of difference,
but that 15 degrees
of difference
puts me in a place
where I'm actually
forced to deal with the argument
and sort of read it through.
And so what I'm
interested in is,
can we start identifying those
people 15 to 30 degrees off
of where we are, and then
find out what they read,
and find out how we
meet them, and sort of
find out how we sort of
have those conversations?
These are the sorts of
systems that I would really
like to be building.
But I've only got sort of
three or four grad students
over there.
And this is a big company.
You guys build a lot
of different things.
I'm really interested in,
can I get other people
in the tech industry who
are interested in exactly
that question that you're
asking to sort of say,
is this perhaps part
of our responsibility?
Is this part of
what we should be
asking our tools to do, is
not just give us what we want,
but possibly giving us
what we need in civic terms
to try to get to a more
inclusive society in one
fashion or another?
Anybody else?
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So people listening to this
talk who may be very interested,
but they're working
on another project,
and a few months pass,
and they forget about it--
how can we foster a more
frequent contact so that this
stays on people's minds?
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN: Well,
I am across the street.
And you can come see us.
And you can actually
get into to my building
without ID, which
is always nice.
But so a couple things--
I sort of soft-pedaled
the Global Voices project.
But there's actually a very
vibrant community of people
around that really working
on this question of,
how would you pay more
attention to the world
and sort of how would you
fight the way in which
those countries are
framed and understood?
And so one of the things
that I would definitely
encourage people to
do is to think about,
is that something
to connect with?
We are doing some
active experiments
on trying to figure
out both, can we
monitor media consumption
voluntarily, sort of opt in?
And when we learn that
media consumption has
certain biases
associated with it,
can we do structured
recommendations of content?
And for me, that strikes me
as a very interesting place--
potential to collaborate.
And we do have students sort
of working on that and sort
of playing with
that, and you guys
would be very welcome to
come across the street
to the Media Lab, have
conversations about that
and sort of figure
out where to go.
The trick in sort
of writing a book
is you're trying
to identify people
who think a problem
is important enough
that they want to put
some time into it.
And so this is sort
of my plea to people
who think this is
interesting enough
that they want to work on it.
And I'm now sort of advising
half a dozen projects
around the world
of people who think
this is an interesting
thing to explore and want
to work together on it.
I would love to be
involved with sort
of more of those conversations.
I would also love to be involved
in conversations with people
who I've got it
wrong and I'm not
framing the question
the right way
or the most provocative way.
But I would hope to
sort of open a door
around this, either to that
existing, thriving community
around Global Voices or
to the nascent community
around civic media that
we have across the street.
Please.
AUDIENCE: I think
also that might
be a good opportunity
for the plug.
If anybody here is interested
in sort of topics like citizen
journalism and stuff like
that, we have a team here
in Cambridge working on
YouTube live streaming,
where we sort of
worry a lot about news
and how live streaming of
news sort of can impact
these kind of questions around
news and citizen journalism
and stuff like that.
And we're now starting work
with MIT Media Lab, actually.
YouTube is funding research
at the MIT Media Lab
to sort of explore these ideas.
So we've been
actually in contact
with Ethan, people who
are interested to work
on these things.
ETHAN ZUCKERMAN: And
precisely the project
we're talking about
working on together
is trying to figure
out, how do you put
enough context around the
live stream of an event
that it's comprehensible to
someone who doesn't know where
it's coming from?
I was looking at
this the other day,
and the protests about the
internet tax in Hungary
were being live-streamed
on YouTube.
And on the one hand, this
was sort of fascinating.
It's really interesting
to see tens of thousands
of Hungarians come out into the
street over an internet access
issue.
The flip side is that my
Hungarian is not very good,
and there's no
information or sort
of context going on on that.
How do we turn that
amazing ability
we have to now be in
the streets of Budapest
watching that protest unfold?
How does that turn
into that opportunity
to actually get informed on it?
So we're excited to work
with you guys on that.
Thank you so much, guys.
Please help yourself to a book.
I'm happy to sign one
if anyone is interested.
I'm happy to sign more than
one if anyone is interested.
It's been really
great to be here.
[APPLAUSE]